All right.
Welcome.
My name is Dan Galpin,
and we're going
to be talking about
garbage today.
I hope everyone is really
excited to hear about garbage.
A little bit about me.
I have spent the last over five
years as a developer advocate
on the Android
team, mostly working
with game developers,
which is why I end up
dealing with so many
low level things,
but also doing a couple of fun
things you might have seen.
I'm really proud of the work
we've done with Udacity.
I worked on both the
Android fundamentals class,
introduction to Android, as well
as the advanced Android class.
And I have had no sleep.
Literally, I have not
slept in about two days.
So this should be exciting.
Yeah, and I think I'm funny.
So I had a confession to make.
If you looked at the
description of this talk,
when Ian Ni-Lewis-- who
you notice is not here--
and I started
planning this talk,
we were thinking
like ocean liner big.
And we wanted to cover
all sorts of things.
We wanted to cover Binder,
and ART, and the OAT
format, services whose
names end in Flinger.
You name it.
But a few weeks ago,
we realized two things.
First, there was no way
we had time for all that.
Even if we could write a talk
that would cover all of that,
we still couldn't
deliver it in 40 minutes.
Secondly, there already a
series of books and talks
called Android
Internals that covered
lots of what we are planning.
So we decided to focus the talk.
So instead, I'm going to talk
about one of the journeys
that we've taken through
the internals of Android.
I should also mention
that I did not write
large chunks of this talk.
Ian Ni-Lewis, my cohort did,
but he couldn't be here today.
I am, however, responsible
for all of the slides.
He wrote a script that
I'm going to read word
for word, because I
will forever stand
in utter aw of his
technical brilliance.
And because I haven't
slept in about a week.
So let's get started.
The great thing about spelunking
through the bowels of Android
is that pretty much
anyone can do it.
It's the beauty of open source.
And you might think that
since I work for Google,
I have some kind of
special advantage
when it comes to
understanding Android.
I mean, any time I want to, I
can walk over and talk directly
to one of the amazing people
that actually wrote the system.
And it is pretty awesome.
But not only do I try to avoid
doing that more than I have to,
the knowledge is actually
pretty much spread about
over lots of people these days.
So while the Android
engineering team is amazing,
and I'm honestly really
fortunate to be working
with them, when I really want
to know how something works,
I'll at least first
get into some code
and try to find out for myself.
So today, I'm going to
tell you a story about how
Ian and I journeyed deep
into the Android runtime
and found out something
for ourselves.
Specifically, it's a
story of how we found out
why you have to be careful
not to waste too much time
when trying to
avoid allocations,
especially when
you're running on ART.
And, we're actually going
to show you how we did it.
This particular story
begins with a deck
of cards, which is exceptionally
appropriate since it also
ends with cards.
Now Ian was writing a demo
that drew playing cards.
It was supposed to be an
experiment about overdraw.
But that actually turned out to
be the least interesting part
of the demo.
Now card games are a
great test for overdraw
because stacks of them have
a lot of overlapping objects,
but none of them are
transparent like these ones are.
So there's a huge difference
between the number of pixels
you draw in the worst
case versus the number you
draw in the best case.
But to get that best
case performance,
you have to figure out exactly
which parts of the card
are visible.
Now there's a general
algorithm for doing that,
but requires a
lot of bookkeeping
because it involves
splitting rectangles
into some unknown number
of smaller rectangles.
Now the thing you need to
understand about Ian who is
doing this is that he
is a C++ programmer.
More than that, he's
a game programmer.
And a game written in C++, this
problem would be the perfect
candidate for some
kind of object pool.
So we decided to keep all of
the rectangles in a simple pool.
Now how many people
out there actually used
SimplePool in their coding?
It's part of the
Support Library.
I don't think he expected
the object pool to make
a huge performance
difference, but he
thought it might help a little.
What surprised us both was
that it didn't help at all.
Instead, it totally tanked.
I mean, the performance
was absolutely abysmal.
And so, we decided
to look for answers.
We started where
most people start
when they have a performance
problem with the sampling
method profiler and Traceview.
How many of you have
used Traceview out there?
Come on, show of hands.
Oh that's good.
You're listening,
that's awesome.
The profiler isn't as good
as Systrace of catching
intermittent performance
spikes, but it's really great
at getting a big picture view
of what's expensive and what
isn't.
And here we are.
The culprit is
SimplePool release.
Now here's what that
code looks like.
That isInPool line looks
kind of suspicious.
It sounds like it might
be a linear search.
And of course, if we look
back at our Traceview output,
we also see that
isInPool there is
right at the top of our list.
So clearly it's costly.
And actually it does
do a linear search.
It goes to check
everything in the array
to see if it's
already in the pool.
So if you have a
really big pool,
it's actually really expensive,
especially since array access
is not particularly cheap.
So we decided to make
an even simpler pool.
Well that was easy.
We'll just make our own pool
with a cabana, waterfall,
a diving board.
I mean with unchecked releases.
It's very easy to
get those mixed up.
We're living on the edge.
And of course, Traceview
output looks like this.
It fixes our performance
problems, yes.
It turns out you should
be really careful
when using SimplePool.
That linear search really
makes large pools slow.
We could pack up
and go home now,
but now we've got some
code to play with.
So we decided to find
out how big of a deal
is allocation in ART anyway.
So we had some crazy
tests like allocating
thousands and thousands
of objects in onDraw.
And we found that in most cases,
unless the object was really
expensive to create,
like a paint object,
it didn't really
affect our frame rate.
And we're like, what?
I mean, no, we didn't
just suddenly find out
that allocations were free.
All that stuff Colt McAnlis
told you is still true.
What this experience taught us
was that we didn't understand
how allocations affected
performance quite as well as we
thought we did.
And when you start seeing
performance numbers that you
don't expect, that's
a perfect time
to start digging into the code.
So off to the debugger.
I know what you're thinking.
I love reading through code as
much as the next crazy person,
but sometimes you just
got to step through it
to understand it.
Now there's a lot of ways to
debug the Android runtime.
Some are easy,
and some are hard.
And let's make things
easy on ourselves.
First-- and this is
going to shock you--
we're actually going to
debug an emulator build.
Now how many of you actually
use the emulator when you're
writing Android software?
OK.
Well, so devices
are kind of finicky.
So are network connections
and USB cables.
We're actually going to be
doing a lot of native debugging.
And unless you're trying to
debug an issue with hardware
code generation, there's really
not a big difference these days
between debugging against the
emulator and a real device.
In addition, when you're
running on the emulator,
you get to run as root.
And our images also include
a version of GDB server.
So you've got super,
super reliable debugging.
Believe it or not if you need to
do native debugging on Android.
Second, we get to
avoid using ADB.
Which is really cool.
Why?
Because ADB was designed to
be cheap, slow, and reliable.
And it really manages to
achieve two of those goals.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, ADB is OK if you're
using the GDB command
line, which I know some
of you are totally into.
So if you're one
of those people,
just go back to your
Emacs or whatever
for a minute or two while
I talk to everyone else.
When I'm stepping
through unknown code,
I really prefer to
use some kind of GUI.
Now Ian is a huge fan of Qt
Creator, because it's free,
and because it's not Eclipse.
But ADB can't handle the
amount of GDB traffic
that an IDE like that generates.
It works for awhile, but at some
point it just decides to quit.
But fortunately, the emulator
has its own IP port redirecter
that doesn't rely on ADB.
And my experience with that is
it it's really, really solid.
Third, download
the AOSP code base
and build your own
emulator image.
Now you don't have to do this,
but it's so totally worth it.
For one thing, you
don't have to worry
about your sources, symbols,
and binaries being in sync.
For another thing--
and this is really
important for this
particular quest--
you can actually
disable optimizations
on modules you want
to debug, which
make stepping through
the code a lot easier.
Now once you have a rock solid
debugger attached to the run
time, it's kind of addictive.
You're seeing Android from
a completely new angle.
It's like you've been poking
around a cave with a candle,
and someone just gave you
this high powered flashlight.
And if you're running
a Windows box,
building Android is a good
excuse to install Linux VM.
All right.
Let's start with my favorite
piece of code, the byte code
interpreter.
Now they're actually two
different implementations
depending on how you compile it.
One is a goto table
implementation,
which is one of
those pieces of code
that simultaneously proves
why C macros are horrible
and why they're never
going to go away.
But fortunately, if you set
the right compiler options,
you get the implementation in
interpreter_switch_impl.cc,
which looks exactly like
you always thought it would,
just one giant switch statement
with a case for each opcode.
If you've been
struggling to figure out
what's going on at
the interpreter,
just seeing this enough
is to make you cry.
It doesn't see as much
traffic as it used to
because of the head
ahead of time compiling.
But if you turn that
off, this piece of code
becomes the Rick's Cafe
Americain of switch statements.
Everybody comes here, which
makes it the perfect place
to set some breakpoints and
learn how the runtime works.
Now since we're trying to
minimize our allocation costs,
maybe we should start
by looking at how object
allocation actually happens?
Now all object allocation
starts at the same place
in this interpreter, which
is this new instance DALVIK
opcode.
But as soon as we get into the
implementation of that opcode,
things get a little abstract.
So it turns out that the ART
memory system is massively
polymorphic.
There are actually
eight different kinds
of allocators that
might be returned
from GetCurrentAllocator.
Now this is one of
those points where
it's really great to be stepping
through in the debugger instead
of just reading the code.
Because we can see exactly
what we're getting,
which is RosAlloc.
I mean, not always, but usually.
And Ros stands for run of
slots, which is basically
a fancy pants way of saying
fixed sized block allocator.
The slot is a fixed size block.
The run is an array
of those blocks.
And the allocator
owns a set of runs.
Now each run has a
different slot size,
so it can hold object
of that size or smaller.
And unlike my diagram, the
number of slots in each run
is actually calculated to make
the run end as close to a page
boundary as possible.
Now this is an
awesome allocator.
It's not the most efficient
as far as memory usage,
but it's got two
really nice advantages.
One is that it's practically
immune to fragmentation.
Second, bookkeeping
is really easy.
You never need to split
or coalesce blocks,
and you don't need to store
the size of each allocation
because the address
of the allocation
tells you everything
you need to know.
So even though you
waste a little space
at the end of any object
that's not exactly
the size of its slot,
you get some of that back
by not having to store any extra
cruft alongside it in the heap.
So not to mention that it avoids
data alignment problems if you
happen to have any of those.
There's one really
interesting way
that RosAlloc is different
from the allocators
you see in things
like game programming.
Because game programmers
tend to use a stack
to keep track of free elements.
Now you could implement that
in a little array of bytes
or shorts that has the
same number of elements
as there are slots
in the run, and it
lets you do both allocations
and the deallocations
in constant time.
RosAlloc on the other hand
tracks free slots in a bitmap.
To allocate, you actually
to look through the bitmap
until you find a zero.
Now, technically that's
an O(n) operation.
And when I first looked at this,
I thought it was kind of weird.
And then I thought it
was kind of interesting.
And then I realized it
was freaking brilliant.
And here's why.
First of, yes, the
allocation is order N.
But remember, these are actually
fairly small little groups
you're allocating from.
So it's N times a
very small constant.
Furthermore, most CPUs can
find the first cleared bit
in a word on a
single instruction.
So the worst case
allocation cost
is just the number of slots
divided by the number of bits
in a machine work.
On Android, we actually negate
the bitmap word and then use
something called _builtin_ffs
to find the index of the first
non-set bit.
So we actually use a
compiler intrinsic for that.
And that's not even the
brilliant part though.
Because the brilliant part is
what happens on deallocation.
Because allocation in a
multi-threaded environment
is a huge pain, the
best way to make it fast
is to remove the concurrency.
Just give each thread its
own separate allocator
and make a rule that
memory has to be
freed on the same thread
that allocated it.
But that really sucks
for garbage collection.
Because part of the
appeal is that you can do
a lot of the work on
a background thread.
After all, we all have
multi-core systems.
We tend to have a core free
that's not doing a lot.
And what you get with
RosAlloc is almost the best
of both worlds.
See, there's actually multiple
bitmaps for every run.
One tracks which
slots are in use,
like I talked about earlier.
But another one
tracked slots that
have been freed by
a different thread.
So instead of
synchronizing the free list
on every deallocation, you can
wait until it's convenience
and apply all pending
deallocations by just
NANDing the two bitmaps.
By the way, I'm sharing a
lot of source code here,
and it's a little small.
So I apologize in
the middle of this.
Once again though, this
is fracking brilliant.
Because you can now-- and yes,
you can have thread local runs.
And locks are
sharded by slot size
so that even shared runs
have way lower contention.
And there's a bunch of other
cool stuff in RosAlloc.
But we should probably move on
before everyone starts calling
me the crazy RosAlloc guy.
So the really sad
thing is that it's
hard to implement--
you really implement
anything this elegant in Java.
You'd end up reinventing
the entire reference system,
and it would be kind of
a maintenance nightmare.
So yeah, allocating
from our object pool
isn't a whole lot faster than
allocating from the normal Java
heap, and it's way more work.
But we kind of expected that.
I mean, no one ever explains
about the cost of allocation
in a garbage collected runtime.
It's always about the
cost of collection.
So the question
is, why aren't we
seeing these massive
collection pauses
when we allocated massive
numbers of short lived objects?
Now RosAlloc gave us a
little bit of a clue.
They didn't spend
all that effort
on concurrency for nothing.
It's not that the garbage
collector is doing nothing,
it's that a lot of its work
is being done somewhere else
other than the main thread.
And it's still work, and
we'd like to minimize it,
but it's not calling causing
the jank that it did on DALVIK.
So there's one piece
left in this puzzle.
And it has to do with
how the GC manages
to do so much of its work
on a background thread.
Now actually, since
we spent so much time
talking about how great the
allocator is at concurrency,
it's probably worth going over
why this is even a problem.
Now the GC has to figure
out which objects are live,
and which are dead.
And it does this by starting
with the object on the stack
and following the
references all the way down
till there are no more
references left to follow.
Every object that got
visited during that procedure
must be live.
Because clearly, there's
a chain of references
that your application could
follow to access that object.
Every object that
get left out is dead,
or at least it's not live.
Now the GC guys tell
me that's a little bit
of an oversimplification.
But it's a good
first approximation.
Thing is, this process
is not lightning fast.
And if it's done concurrently,
then your application
is busy connecting,
and disconnecting,
and reconnecting
references while the GC
is trying to trace them.
So let's say that object A
has a reference to object B.
And object C has a reference
type that's currently null.
Now for whatever
reason, the GC visits
object C before because it
visits object A. Following me?
OK.
Now let's say that after
the GC has visited C,
but before it visits A, you give
object B to object C and null
out A's reference.
For all the GC can tell, A and
C both have a null reference.
And it never even saw
B. So the question
is, how do you fix this?
And it turns out
the answer to that
question tells a lot about
how we can shoot ourselves
in the foot by trying to
outsmart the garbage collector.
And it takes us back to
the subject of cards.
If you take another look at
the glorious switch statement
that it's at the heart of
the SLAVIC interpreter,
you'll notice that
a lot of opcodes
have an extra call in them.
Then this call to check
suspend is a checkpoint.
It's a place where
the thread checks
to see if the GC want
it to do anything.
Among other things,
this check lets
the GC tell the thread
to stop completely,
which is what it has to do if
it wants to get an accurate
count of which objects are
dead and which ones are alive.
And this is called the GC pause.
Now clearly, one way to make
sure the GC gets an accurate
count is just to visit the
objects all over again.
But that would be a
colossal waste of time.
I mean, that would be
like a cupcake move.
So instead, how
about how we just
revisit the objects
that got changed
while we were busy doing our
first pass on the object graph.
But now you're talking.
That's some Gingerbread
level thinking my friends.
So how do we tell
what's changed?
Let's go back to that switch
statement one last time.
Now you probably
haven't noticed this,
but there's actually a
specific set of opcodes
just for moving references.
And you know, that might
strike you as being odd,
because references are
just four byte binary
values, same as integers.
Why not just reuse the existing
integer moving opcodes?
And this one takes a
little bit more digging,
because the answer is actually
several layers down in the call
stack, underneath
some templates,
and macros, and
some random cruft.
But eventually you get at this
thing called WriteBarrierField.
Now the word barrier is a little
overloaded in computer science.
Here it means something
that the runtime
has to do before writing
to a reference field.
There's also the concept
of a read barrier.
But it's really
not that important
to this particular discussion.
Anyway, take a look at what
WriteBarrierField does.
It calls mark card.
See, I told there'd be cards.
All right.
In this case, a card is
just an area of memory.
It's kind of like a page,
only it's not the same size.
And besides, that
word was taken.
So we call it a card.
Now marking the card just says,
hey, something in this memory
has changed.
Now why do we even have cards?
And it's really for the
same reason we have pages.
So we can have
metadata about memory
that takes up less room than
the memory we're describing.
So for pages, we keep data
like whether it's read only,
or executable, or any of
that other and protect stuff.
For cards, it's pretty
much just dirty or clean.
It's just a write, if you
look at the source code.
It's not even an atomic.
Which, by the way,
we can get away
with because there's
no read, modify, write.
In a concurrent environment,
it's just a write.
And the read is done
during the GC pause
where the value can't change.
So what's so important
about the card table?
Given the information
in the cards,
the GC doesn't have to
rescan every single object
during the pause.
It can focus its
attention on the objects
that might be dirty.
Now this idea extends far
beyond just finding the object
to change in the last
concurrent scan by the way.
There are plenty of objects
that almost never change.
For instance, class objects.
If we can, we want to avoid
scanning those objects ever.
And we can get away with that,
because if for some reason
those objects ever do change,
their cards will be marked.
Now the card idea isn't perfect.
For instance, if a
card happens to contain
more than one object,
there's no way
to tell which object is dirty.
All of them have
to be rescanned.
Even worse, an array
of objects count
as one object when it
comes to card marking.
That's one object with a
whole lot of references.
Which means if you insert or
remove an object from an array,
the entire array gets rescanned.
So now we come full
circle because our pool
of card rectangles
might actually end up
as a victim of card marking.
I know there's a country
song in there somewhere.
But it's only one
of several factors
that make allocations
cheaper on ART.
And I wish I had actually
more slides to talk
through the rest of them, but
I'll talk about a few of them.
One of them is better
collection pass scheduling.
Now ART in general tends to do
a better job of figuring out
when to run collection passes,
which means that GC for alloc
is a thing of the past.
And two, it keeps
a list of objects
that have been allocated
since the last GC.
So when you add that
information to the card table,
ART gets the ability to
collect super short lived
objects without even
triggering a GC pause.
And that's why allocating
ludicrous numbers
of simple object doesn't kill
ART the way it did DALVIK.
And two-- sorry, I
already said this.
So finally, let
me in conclusion,
because this is going
to be really short guys.
So don't walk out of here
and tell your friends
that allocations
don't matter anymore.
First of all, we
don't want to incur
the wrath of Colt. And
besides, the point of this talk
isn't necessarily just to
add to your stock of protips,
but hopefully it's to give you
a little bit of understanding
of how things are working inside
of Android and how you can
[INAUDIBLE] and enjoy going
through Android yourself.
So I hope I've given you some of
the tools and encouragement you
need to go on your
own adventures
through the Android code base.
I mean, after all, what
else is open source
for if we can't learn from it?
So we're looking forward
to hearing your stories.
If you want to contact me,
that's where I can be found.
And thank you all.
And you all get 20
minutes back or so.
So enjoy the rest of your
time here at the barbecue.
And if you have any
questions, I am more than
happy to take them now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]